Ich muss aber noch mal ein Streaming, also den zweiten Rechner hochfahren, dass ich was
sehe, dass ich den Chat im Blick haben kann, deswegen dauert es kurz noch, der ist gerade
erst am booten, geht nicht so schnell, wahrscheinlich macht er jetzt erstmal Windows Update oder
sowas.
Ok, die Musik ist mir noch ein bisschen zu einschläfernd.
Ja ok, mein Wink, besser als das andere, bei dem anderen bist du wirklich komplett weggepennt.
So, wie gesagt, erstmal schnell den zweiten Rechner noch starten.
Wieso Commodore Hype und nicht PogChamp, so erstmal, hat keinen Sinn, kann man beides
nehmen, je nachdem was man nehmen will.
Wenn mein Computer hängt, was ist hier los, was soll das, warum hängt der, wahrscheinlich
weil ich noch Skype drauf installiert habe auf dem alten, der hat auch schon Skype installiert,
noch schlimmer, ich habe sogar noch Overwatch darauf installiert, ja, was ist denn da los,
kein Wunder, da würde ich auch nicht booten wollen, Overwatch und Skype, ja dann ist kein
Wunder, dass er nicht bootet, aber echt, Skype ist echt, so, nee, nicht auf Headstar, irgendwo
lokal in der VM, ich will das auch nicht auf dem Headstar Server installieren, das habe
ich nicht vor, da irgendwie ZFS zu betreiben, ich habe mir nur überlegt, es wäre teilweise
ganz cool, wenn ich schon mein ganzes System oder zumindest das System mit den ganzen Containers
drauf, wenn ich das einfach Snapshotten könnte, bevor ich einen Upgrade mache, ich werde es
wahrscheinlich eh nicht machen, aber ehrlich gesagt hat mich einfach nur mal interessiert,
wie so das Date, das Date von ZFS ist, mit dieser Verschlüsselung, die sie jetzt eingebaut
haben, wir haben vor Jahren, haben wir das schon mal uns angeguckt, mal gucken, ob ich
das noch finde, ja noch mal, Archive, noch mal Archive, hier geht das, das ist wirklich
schon ganz lange her, ZFS, habe ich ZFS, booten von ZFS, Verschlüsselung, ok, guck mal, ich
habe mir das angeguckt, vor über 3 Jahren und witzlicherweise ist das immer noch nicht
überall mit drinne, also manchmal mahlen so die Open Source Mühlen langsam, als habe
ich nicht geguckt, wann war das, mache nämlich mal den Stream auf, da kann ich mir was abgucken
vor einem eigenen Stream von vor 3 Jahren, hier irgendwo, ZFS, tja Google, sieht man
das hier, nice, warum gibt es denn den Stream, Sebaro, was ist denn mit dem Stream, ich glaube
das hier ist das eigentliche, Alter 5, Leute ich habe 5 Stunden gestreamt damals, da hatte
ich noch Ausdauer, ok hier wird gerade rumgebastelt, das muss ich mir merken, ja das muss ich mir
merken, das probiere ich nämlich nachher auch noch aus, also hier kann ich meinen eigenen
Stream abgucken, Alter haben wir nicht schon Musik, was ein bisschen mehr abgeht, nein,
irgendwas, sonst müssen wir uns wieder den geben, das ist Epogger Soundtrack, aber ich
will nicht jedes Mal den gleichen Soundtrack anmachen, ok, das ist kein Problem, ich danze
bei fast nichts, ok lass wir das jetzt mal laufen, Dubstep Chillmix, ne, heute nicht,
außerdem weiß ich dann nicht wie die Copyright ist, Game Musik geht eigentlich immer, BUMBA
DA BING BA DA BUM, Danke schon für den Sub, Massive Subscription, oh, Leute ich habe es
kaputt gemacht, jetzt geht es wieder, hier wird es abgekackt, jetzt soll ich mal kurz
den Chat überfliegen, ob ich nichts vergessen habe, was auch immer, ja kenne ich, habe ich
vor zig Jahren mal verwendet, Stream Recycling, ja, ich könnte auch auf den alten Stream reacten
oder gar nichts machen, ich versuche das mit der Native Encryption, ich wollte es mal ausprobieren,
ich habe das ja vor Jahren schon ausprobiert, da hat glaube ich alles geklappt, aber war
äußerst experimental alles noch, so, schmeißen wir erstmal die VM an mit dem Board, dann
die Stream VM an, Stream VM und dann, da kann ich das Fragen Board anschmeißen, alten Stream
abspielen, abgehen, ja der ist 5 Stunden lang gewesen und ich glaube zwischendrin war ich
irgendwie eine halbe Stunde im Winterhess und da bin ich einfach abgegangen, das weiß
ich noch, den habe ich auch letztens gesehen, bei Halse glaube ich war das, weiß gar nicht
warum die Leute alle so scharf sind auf dem Windows XP Hügel, angeblich, angeblich ist
der Windows XP Hügel nicht nachbearbeitet, der Sache traue ich nicht so ganz ehrlich
gesagt, irgendwie sagt mir die Musiker überall nicht zu.
Ja, das geht schon, so, kurz hier die VM anschmeißen,
achso, was hatte ich denn, what the fuck, der Desktop ist poggers, sagt nix, massive, ich
glaube, hier war der Kram, Restore Session, ja kann man gleich machen, der MPP-Garboard
am Start, zack, so, habe ich noch irgendwas vergessen letztes Mal, ich lösche das jetzt
erstmal vorletztes Mal, öh, warum geht es nicht weg, will nicht, jawoll, excellent, mehr
Schraub, Twitch Prime, Dankeschön für den Sub, exzellente, extrem exzellente Subscription,
Leute habt ihr schon gesehen, mein Serverraum sieht langsam tatsächlich benutzbar aus,
schaut mal hier, übrigens Ubuntu hat gewonnen, bei meiner Umfrage auf Twitter, ok, ok, Ubuntu
ich meine, ich meine natürlich, so, mit 65%, und zwar, wir hatten eben gesagt, ich hab
es gerade gesehen, oh, das Scam Train ist am Start, The General Slane, 10 Monate, exzellente
Subscription, Moin Albi, wie ging nochmal der Befehl, wenn man Putty auf einen Server
gehen wollte, der mit Lux verschlüsselt wurde, neu gesteckt wurde, egal nicht, einfach PSSH
draufgehen, wenn du dann drauf bist, kannst du, öh, Crypt Setup Unlock oder einfach nur
Unlock oder so, weiß es nicht genau, aus dem Kopf jetzt, warum ist denn die Firefox Adresszeit
so fett, ah ne, ist schon erledigt, ok, exzellent, so, also wollen wir mal einen neuen Fall mit
Demian, also, schauen wir mal, genau, ich wollte euch ja mal meinen Serverraum zeigen,
genau, kommt mal hier, der macht doch jetzt schon ein bisschen mehr her, sieht jetzt auch
ordentlicher aus, es ist aber noch nicht alles richtig, richtig nice, hier unten beispielsweise,
habe ich einfach alles reingestopft, weil ich wollte den Kram endlich von oben weg haben,
was meint ihr, wie viele Leute haben reingezoomt, ob sie mein Unity Media Passwort erkennen,
beinahe es haben viele gemacht, seid ihr schon drin, NS, nicht NSA Zoom, NAVY CIS Zoom, aber
das verwende ich gar nicht, das Passwort, was da unten steht, also umsonst gehack Sword,
kann man so eine gescheite USB empfehlen, nicht die, nicht die, die ich habe, ja, ist
immer noch Unity Media, ja, wie gesagt, hier unten habe ich die Kabel einfach reingestopft,
kann man das vielleicht mal normaler skalieren, hier unten habe ich die Kabel einfach reingestopft,
dass ich hier oben den 3D Drucker drauf stellen kann, übrigens, man sieht mein Druckbett
ist ein bisschen verkratzt schon, so aus dem Winkel sieht man das eigentlich ganz gut,
was ist eigentlich der eigentliche Zweck von so einem kleinen Raum, das was du da siehst,
genau das ist der Zweck, der steht hinter mir und da ist eine Tür dazwischen, das heißt,
selbst wenn da was mit Lüfter läuft, höre ich es nicht, wie kommt man eigentlich an
die Schlafsack Jogginghose, hä, einfach Jogginghose bestellen, die viel zu groß ist, ja, da ist
jetzt hier halt alles mögliche drin, was man so braucht, hier oben wird ein bisschen
Zeug gesammelt an Kleinteile, hier ist der ganze Werkzeugkrempel und hier ist der 3D
Drucker, Netzwerkzeug und unten drunter so ein Low-Power-Server, macht auf jeden Fall
jetzt schon ein bisschen mehr her, als das letzte Mal, wo ich das Video gemacht habe,
übrigens hat einer von euch eine Ahnung, bei diesen Unify Access Points, die Dinger
sind ja eigentlich dafür gedacht, also diese Eier hier, ne, was ist denn jetzt XG schon
wieder, oh fuck, also 10G, easy, Schnapper, bisschen teuer, zumindest hat er, also so sind
die ja eigentlich gedacht, wie man sie montieren sollte, ne, hat irgendeiner eine Ahnung, ob
das einen großen Unterschied macht, wie das so abstrahlungstechnisch ist, ob das, ob das,
wirklich ob das einen großen Unterschied macht zwischen an der Decke oder an der Wand
oder auf dem Boden oder auf dem, also ne, also hinlegen, an die Decke machen oder an,
also ist halt die Frage, entweder Kopf über, Kopf nach oben oder halt, ja, aufrecht an der
Wand, du fandst an der Decke besser, ja optisch oder von abstrahlungs, also da hast du besseren
Empfang gehabt danach, ja, weil ich hätte ja die Möglichkeit zu sagen, ich kann den
einfach hier an die Decke machen, ich machs aber wahrscheinlich an die Wand, Decke ist
so, Decke sackt ein bisschen, ich glaube ihn an die Werkzeugwand hier unten hin zu hängen
ist nicht so gut, ich glaube Axis Points mögen kein Metall dahinter, hab ich irgendwie so
denen das Gefühl, ja, ja okay, da muss ich mal gucken, ich habe hier neben noch Platz,
nimm doch die Dose ab, was, also ich hab, ich glaube ich werd das so machen, ich mach
den Axis Point gar nicht in den Raum hier, ich mach hier durch das Kabelkanal rüber
ins Wohnzimmer ein Kabel und da leg ich den dann hin, ja der ist von 2018, der ist ein
bisschen älter, der hat 3D Drucker schon, genau und die Switche die man noch im Video
gesehen hat, die sind jetzt auch alle weg, hier unten sieht man noch, ne man sieht eigentlich
gar nichts mehr, ne, das einzige was man hier unten noch sieht ist aktuell das Unity Media
Box und hier neben steht der Mikrotik Router, ich hab übrigens, Leute ich hab es übrigens
geschafft, letztens hat doch im Stream einer gefragt, warum machst du kein PoE mit dem,
ich hab ja das Ding hier als Router, letztens hat mich ja einer im Stream noch gefragt
warum machst du kein PoE und da hab ich gesagt, ich mach kein PoE, weil also das Teil, ne,
der macht ja auf allen Ports hier, macht da PoE und da hab ich gesagt, ja das liegt daran,
weil die Axis Points andere Spannung brauchen als der Router läuft, aber was ich jetzt
gemacht hab, ich hab nen TP-Link Netzteil genommen, für so nen PoE Injector und genau
hier war ne Netzteil dabei, so ein kleines Furznetzteil war dabei mit 48 Volt und ich
hab einfach vorne abgeschnitten und hab nen neuen Stecker drauf gemacht, so dass das 48
Volt Netzteil jetzt da dran passt und dann hab ich den Axis Point angeschlossen und
musste im Web GUI, musste ich sagen Force PoE, sonst hat es nicht funktioniert, Force PoE
und jetzt läuft der Axis Point, der UniFi Axis Point läuft jetzt mit PoE vom Router,
also hat mal wieder der Chat Recht gehabt, hast du schon den neuen Wi-Fi 6 gesehen, ja,
ich war sogar letztens kurz davor mir einen zu bestellen, aber ich hab mir dann gedacht,
wozu, ich hab nicht ein Gerät was Wi-Fi 6 kann, aber Hauptsache mal bestellen, ja, macht
nen Unterschied, ja ich werds mal ein bisschen ausprobieren, bisschen rumrücken das Ding
und gucken, ich hab irgendwas noch übersehen vorhin, 1500 Kleines, ja die Dinger, das ist
wahrscheinlich, kannst du wahrscheinlich Fußballstadion mit bestücken, hast du schon die Stepper ausgetauscht,
ne, also ich hab an dem 3D Drucker gar nix gemoddet, das einzige was ich gemoddet hab
an dem 3D Drucker ist, ich hab hier vorne, man erkennts ja grad, man erkennts hier ein
bisschen, ich hab hier vorne so nen Ring ausgedruckt mit LEDs unten dran, also ihr seht ja hier
ist das Licht, das Licht kommt von hier runter, also das ist so ne Fassung hab ich ausgedruckt
und dann so nen LED Ring gekauft und den LED Ring hab ich hier innen dran an diese, was
ist das 12 Volt oder so angeschlossen und jedes Mal wenn der 3D Drucker jetzt angeht
und warm wird, also sprich sobald der Lüfter da innen drin angeht, geht hier der LED Ring
unten an, das ist tatsächlich ganz praktisch, ansonsten hab ich noch so irgendwas, ich hab
da oben auf ganz abenteuerliche Art und Weise ne Raspberry Pi Cam dran geklebt, wie man
sieht, sieht nicht sonderlich advanced aus, ja, aber man erkennts hier, hier ist die Raspberry
Pi Cam obendran, aber da mach ich die, ich hab mir mal so ne UniFi Kamera bestellt, weil
ich die ausprobieren wollte, fand ich nicht sonderlich gut, aber hierfür ist die optimal,
die ist klein und ich glaub die häng ich dann irgendwie, frag mich nicht, hier neben
irgendwie hin oder vielleicht daneben oder so, das mit den LED im Drucker, ja das ist
echt praktisch hier, ihr seht ja, das Licht was ihr hier seht, das kommt von dieser, kommt
von dieser LED Leiste, von dieser Lampenleiste hier, übrigens weiß jemand ob es diese Dinger
zum Nachkaufen gibt, bestimmt oder, ich komm mal kurz gucken, Druck, Platte, Druck, Bett,
so was da, 80 Euro, falsch, das magnetische brauchst du, na was soll ich suchen, ma, hier
magnetisches Druckbett, ok wisst ihr was Leute, ich komm auch mit ner verkratzten Druckplatte
zu Recht, kein Problem, es haftet ja noch alles, es haftet ja noch alles, ich hab gedacht
wenn es jetzt 20 Euro kostet oder so, kann ich mir eine holen, es könnte aber auch sein,
es könnte aber auch sein, dass das gar nicht verkratzt ist, sondern dass das einfach nur
dreckig ist und ich müsste das mal wirklich ordentlich putzen, wie putzt man so was am
besten, Alkohol nehmen einfach, hast du schon angefangen, nö, noch gar nicht, ich hab
noch gar nicht angefangen, ich hab noch nicht über den Vm erstellt, null, show off Amazon,
8000, what the, das geb ich jetzt nicht bei Amazon einfach ein, wer weiß wo ich dann rauskomme,
irgendwo bei Monka Toss oder so, ok, ich trau euch, chat, chat, ich trau euch jetzt, ich
kopier das jetzt hier einfach mal rein, Drucker, Flexibel, abnehmbar, Magnetplatte, ne, ich
brauch doch irgendwas mit Heizung drin, exellent, aber richtig exellent, ex, exellent, exellent
ist das, na gut, lang genug geschwätzt, ich wollte mal kurz gucken, ich hab nämlich irgendwas,
sind normale Gebrauchsspuren, echt, also hier neben hab ich auf jeden Fall einen richtig
fetten Kratzer produziert, da hab ich das Bett falsch gelevelt, also ich hab, das ist
vielleicht ein Fehler, das sag ich euch jetzt gleich mal, dass ihr den nicht auch machen
müsst, und zwar, dass ihr den nicht auch macht, und zwar, wenn man das Druckbett levelt, das
macht man ja oftmals, indem man irgendwelche Testdinger ausdruckt, ne, es gibt dann, hier
seht ihr diese Kästchen, die sind eigentlich ganz gut, es gibt so Testdrucke, wo man sehen
kann, ob sein Druckbett gescheit eingestellt ist, das druckt dann so kleine Quadrate und
so, so, und was ich, was ich gemacht hab, ist, ich hab nen Testdruck gemacht, hab festgestellt,
ok, hier ist ein bisschen zu hoch, hier ist ein bisschen zu niedrig, und dann hab ich
es eingestellt, so und das Problem ist, man muss das im abgekühlten Zustand machen, also
das dauert, weil das Problem ist, wenn die, die Platte wird so 50 Grad warm oder so, wenn
die, oder 60, auf jeden Fall ein bisschen wärmer, also sprich, das Ding dehnt sich,
das Ding dehnt sich aus, und ich hab's dann halt irgendwie geschafft, so, so halb abgekühlt
und halb warm das Ding zu leveln, und irgendwie war dann halt das Problem, dass wenn das Ding
wieder richtig heiß geworden ist, dann, dann hat's, dann hat's dann andere Abmaße gehabt
und sowas, also, richtig, richtig kacke, man muss, man muss das wirklich immer im gleichen
Zustand messen, na zumindest hab ich's da geschafft beim, beim rumdrehen, dass der,
der Druckkopf hier auf der Platte mal geschliffen ist, hier oben in der Ecke, war kein, das
war einfach nicht so geil, nicht so nice war das, so, ich lad mir mal kurz den Debian
ISO runter, gibt's das, was brauch ich denn überhaupt, ich hab so ne komische Anleitung
hier gesucht, wir machen das mal nach der Anleitung, das da muss, was, Gnome ISO, oh
jetzt hab ich das Wort gesagt, Leute, das Gnome ISO, ich wusste, der Chat kommt drauf,
Alter, das ist so geil, jemand der da, der im Stream nicht dabei war, der checkt überhaupt
nicht was Sache ist, Rufi, um all die Leute, ich lad das jetzt mal runter, um all die Leute
einzuweihen, die nicht dabei waren, ok, ich soll ernsthaft, die wollen ernsthaft das Debian
Server von einem fuck Gnome installieren, ok, ich mach das jetzt einfach, was auch immer
die sagen, ok, also während das runter lädt, mal ganz kurz, und da lese ich die restlichen
Sachen im Chat, um die Leute einzuweihen, die da nicht dabei waren, und zwar, ich hatte
mal, ich hatte mal nen Kollege, auf der Arbeit, den haben wir, der ist ein bisschen durchgedreht
mit der Zeit, und zwar, den haben die damals eingekauft, also typische, typische Business
Stonks Entscheidung war das wieder, den haben die eingekauft, weil die lustigerweise passt
eigentlich heute richtig gut zum Thema, weil die Solaris und ZFS machen wollten, mal ganz
kurz bei mir auf der Arbeit, ist schon ein paar Jahre her, und dann haben die den eingekauft,
und als der dann da war, ist ihnen eingefallen, wir haben den jetzt für ein halbes Jahr eingekauft,
aber wir machen jetzt gar keinen Solaris und ZFS mehr, also typische Business Stonks Entscheidung
wieder, irgendwas gesagt, dann geplant und dann nicht gemacht, ja, so, und der Typ, der
ist mit der Zeit ein bisschen durchgedreht, weil der war dann am Start, war eigentlich
Experte für Solaris und ZFS, und musste dann irgendwelche ganz anderen Sachen machen,
und der ist dann, der hat dann quasi von Woche zu Woche, konntest du zugucken, wie der Typ
immer mehr durchgedreht ist im Kopf, und der hat das irgendwie so geschafft, seinen Desktop
so einzustellen, dass wenn er mit der Mauszeige an den Bildschirmrand gekommen ist, dass dann
sein PC-Speaker gesummt hat, also der ist da mit der Mauszeige an den Bildschirmrand
gekommen, und der hat seinen PC-Speaker gemacht, und daraufhin hat er dann immer das Ganze
auf seinen Gnome-Desktop geschoben, und hat dann immer gesagt, der scheiß Gnome, das
war dann irgendwann so der Running Gag, also der Typ, der hat wirklich Dachschaden gehabt
mit der Zeit, ja, und es wurde dann, und es wurde dann noch schlimmer, irgendwann hat
er dann angefangen, alle möglichen Sachen merkwürdig auszusprechen, und dann hat er
irgendwelche Ruby-Skripte gemacht, und dann saß er dann wirklich vorm Rechner, und hat
dann quasi gesagt, Ruby, der scheiß Gnome, das war echt vorbei, der Typ ist wirklich
zunehmend von Woche zu Woche immer mehr abgedreht, so, und daher kommt das halt, das habe ich
vor einer Weile schon mal erzählt, irgendwie fand das der Chat so geil, dass die immer
im Chat, dass jetzt immer mindestens einer im Chat schreibt, wenn ich sage Gnome, der
scheiß Gnome, ja, aus welchem Grund macht man das, ich habe keine Ahnung, ich habe
absolut keinen Plastenschirm, warum man seinen Desktop so einstellt, so, also, kurz, kurz,
kurz Chat lesen. Irgendwas war da doch, Freund. Warten wir schon. Doch, doch, doch, doch, das
geht per SSH, das habe ich vor drei Jahren im Stream schon gemacht, aber ich weiß nicht
mehr wie. Ja, wie gesagt, nicht die USB, die ich habe, die sackt. Ne, habe ich nicht. Habe
ich auch nicht. Wobei, warum habe ich denn meine VR mit dem Pepega Board an? Kann ich
doch hier reingucken, was die Leute geschrieben haben, siehste, ja. Doch, doch, das geht angeblich
schon. Okay, muss ich mal gucken. Alles darüber zerstört die Platte, wegen dafür kann ich
jetzt 3D Lack. Aha. Ich hatte auch mal eine ganze Weile ZFS-Dings bei mir am Laufen, aber
schon wieder her und das war total oversized für mich, aber ich wollte es mir jetzt einfach
mal wieder angucken. Ubuntu geht auch, okay, ich werde es jetzt gleich sehen. Huh? Download
ist kaputt. Ja, der Download, LOL, das ist mir gar nicht aufgefallen. Der Download ist
kaputt. Was auch immer. Ich kann die 3060 nicht zum Preis-Champ hinzufügen, weil sich
doch kaum Shops Links dazu haben. Okay, also wir legen jetzt die VM an, easy. Auf geht's,
VM. New. Custom. Workstation, alles klar. Installer-Dist, machen wir später selbst.
Linux, Debian, 16bit. Das ganze erstellen wir aber nicht da, sondern auf E, nicht auf
D, auf E. E, VMs. CacWate. Next. CPUs. Vier, wenn schon dann richtig. Fangen wir mal an
vier Cores. RAM 4096. Bäm. NAT. Next. Next. Next. Single File, 20G, reichen. Next. Next.
So, und jetzt müssen wir noch einstellen, das habe ich schon mal im Vorfeld in der Anleitung
geguckt. UEFI-Boot müssen wir einstellen. War das jetzt nochmal versteckt? Ach nee,
das kann man erst nach dem Erstellen einstellen, glaube. Geht da, ne? Advanced UEFI-Boot, excellent,
excellent. Gut, so, mountainen wir mal die CD. Oder besser gesagt, das ISO-CD klingt
jetzt irgendwie verkehrt. Debian. Weil die coolen Leute natürlich Debian sagen und die
sagen ja auch Jubantu. So, Pawn. Bäm. I finished installing. Live, alles klar. So, jetzt muss
ich erstmal kurz gucken, wie das funktioniert. Stretch. Guest. Ja, wunderbar. So, also jetzt
muss ich erstmal die Anleitung, die Anleitung aufmachen, wie das Ganze hier funktioniert.
Per Default nimmt sich ZF5, ja. Ja, ja, ja, ich weiß. Aber es ist ja auch ein Gerücht,
dass man so ultra viel RAM braucht, ne? Also die, bei FreeNAS ist das witzig oder generell
auch bei, im Forum und sowas, da kommen die Leute dann an irgendwie mit, was ist das,
sind Gigabyte pro Gigabyte oder irgendwie so, es gibt da so ganz komische Regeln, dass
du am Ende dann auch im Heimbereich irgendwie einen neuen G brauchen würdest oder sowas,
dass alle schwach sind. Der Kram, der läuft auch mit weniger RAM. Natürlich nicht für
ein Büro, wo alle Leute gleichzeitig drauf zugreifen, ja. Und auch nicht, wenn man De-duplication
macht oder sowas. Das ist, ja gut, für De-duplication braucht man extrem viel RAM. Und, also das
ist total übertrieben, das braucht man eigentlich gar nicht, wenn man da nur nichts macht und
einmal im Monat drauf zugreift, ja. Wenn man natürlich gewisse Performance gewährleisten
will und auch Leute parallel drauf zugreifen, ist das wieder was anderes. Der gleiche Kram
wie ECC-only, es ist ja auch Schwachsinn. Es ist auf jeden, also es ist sinnvoll ECC-RAM
zu nehmen, wenn man ein System hat, das das kann, ja. Aber das wird auch nicht unsicherer
dadurch, wie andere Fallsysteme, wenn man kein ECC-RAM hat. Wieso? Das sollte eigentlich
ISNI-Direct-CPU-Support-mäßig sein. Ja, schauen wir mal. Na, das, es macht auch, ja genau,
es macht auch überhaupt keine Probleme. Windows-V habe ich ausgeschaltet, dass ich nichts leake,
falls du irgendwelche Passwörter mal kopieren musst und sowas. Hier ist ja Streaming-Setup
hier. Hopp meiert. Danke schön, zwei Monate. Big Brain-Subscription. Das ist kaputt, das
wundert mich nicht. Genau, also wo habe ich jetzt hier die Anleitung? Da, bam. Okay. Blablabla,
blablabla, blablabla, blablabla. Okay, step, prepare install environment. Boot Debian
Linux. Oh, das ist hier das, dass der Stallman sich nicht aufregt. Debian Knu Linux bitte
schön, ja? Es ist nicht etwa einfach nur Debian oder Linux, es ist Debian Knu Linux. Gibt
ja so, ähm, wie soll man das sagen? Etwas, äh, Leute, die so Grundsatzdiskussionen mögen.
Da ist das, wenn man da nicht Knu Linux dabei sagt, dann... Naja, okay, if prompted log in
user Passport live, connect your system to internet, ja, ja, ja, okay, alles klar, also
ich soll einloggen mit user live, bam, muss ich nicht. Alles klar. Oh, hohe Auflösung,
hohe Auflösung. Boot, Debian, da haben wir doch schon, user live, okay. Setup an update
repos, also das muss ich da jetzt eintragen. Wir machen jetzt Trick 17, wir installieren
jetzt vmware tools, dass ich ordentlich copy pasten kann. Mal gucken, ob man das live macht,
wie kriege ich überhaupt ein Terminal? Terminal, excellent. Kann man hier die Auflösung irgendwie
ändern? Ich meine, das ist gnome, da weiß man nie, ob es funktioniert. Äh, kann man
die auf... Ey, hat jemand einen Plan, wie man in gnome die Auflösung ändert? Display,
da war es, warte mal. Ist auch geil, ne, eines der wichtigsten Sachen ist natürlich hier
unter, die weiße ist versteckt. Okay, die ordentliche Auflösung gibt es schon mal nicht,
wir installieren uns jetzt einfach vmware tools, easy. Zuduo, oh, i, Kakao-Tastatur.
Open vm, da kann man nichts, ist copy pasten. Wie, gibt es nicht? Ah ne, ich hab gar keine
Autovervollständigung. Open, tja die Debian ISO Open vm tools, ich weiß nicht, wie man
das schreibt. Absearch, vm tools, vm, tools, oh man, ich brauch keine Kokona-Tastatur,
please. Ah ja, hier, okay, abinstall, open vm tools, desk, deskoop, deskoop, zack, damit
die Tastatur umstellen, das ist ja ätzend, zack, Maus, Keyboard, is, alter gnome, please,
wie stellt man hier sowas ein? Language, input sources, jawoll, alles klar, German,
ich darf nix adden, alter, German, ja wunderbar, so und jetzt Englisch weg, zack, haben wir
es jetzt auf Deutsch? Ja, yes, okay, open vm tools haben wir installiert, dann sollte
ich eigentlich jetzt nen Fullscreen bekommen, wenn das richtig, oder geht das? Ah, man muss
noch, okay, System, ctl, start, vm, vm tools, d oder sowas, ne, ach meine Güte, open vm
tools, nope, äh, wie ging das nochmal, System, ctl, lists, lists, units, oder sowas, genau,
äh, live tools, what, hat er das jetzt ordentlich installiert, was muss ich denn starten, ne,
ich hab keine Ahnung, ich kann nicht rebooten, das ist ne live cd, ich will einfach nur copy
pasten können auf der live cd, open vm tools, was ist es, open minus vm tools, ne, okay,
wir lassen uns jetzt von vmware erklären, diese vmware Artikel sind immer so super hilfreich,
ups, ab, start, lull, ah easy, nice, alles klar, passt, ja, kaum macht man es richtig,
funktioniert es auch, sehr, okay, jetzt können wir uns nämlich die Anleitung sogar hier rein
kopieren, und dann easy, easy as fuck, bam, das ist immer live cd copy paste, so muss
das sein, also, hier sind wir, hier sind wir stehen geblieben, so, also, bootdings, setup
ein, update repositories, okay, wir machen erstmal das Ding ein bisschen größer, und
das allerwichtigste, wir brauchen, äh, wo ist die font size, ach da, ich brauch ein
bisschen größere font, ich bin ja schon alt, und, wir machen irgendwie was, ja, so, okay,
geht das bei virtualbox, ja, das muss bei virtualbox genauso gehen, so, also, okay,
dann machen wir das jetzt mal, ich mach jetzt einfach mal richtig, Anleitungslowbob, setup
ein, update repos, mach ich, bam, äh, okay, also, das kann ich wieder rausschmeißen, alles
klar, update, optional install open ssh server, ja, die Idee ist eigentlich gar nicht schlecht,
da kann ich das vom zweiten System aus machen, ist vielleicht gar nicht so doof, also, der
Witz hat echt langsam so ein Bart schon, das kannst du nicht bei jedem Song bringen, so,
das brauchen wir zwar nicht, aber vielleicht müssen wir uns da später drauf einloggen,
noch mal haben wir eine IP gekriegt, ach, ich sehe eine NAT-IP, da komm ich eh nicht
dran, hallo, hast du schon das neue gnome 40 gesehen, das sind 3 Wochen, ne, ich bin
kein gnome-benutzer, gnome, äh, könnte mir nicht egaler sein als desktop-umgebung, kde
genauso, ich muss euch ehrlich sagen, ich mag keine, keinerlei linux-desktop-umgebung,
brauch ich ja nicht, kann da, ich muss ja nicht, nicht von anderen vor allem machen,
ich mag keine linux-desktop-umgebung, weder gnome, noch kde, und auch nicht gnome, xfce,
geht irgendwo noch, aber finde ich auch nicht gut, ähm, wir können uns gleich mal angucken,
wir können uns nachher mal gnome 40, was es da neues gibt, im zweifelsfall, im zweifelsfall
machen die wieder irgendwelche komischen dinger, die keiner haben will, ähm, was gibt's denn
sonst noch so für desktop-gedöns, äh, lxd und sowas, ice-wm und so, ist alles nicht
mein fall, das einzige was ich verwende ist i3, und das ist ja kein desktop, das ist im
prinzip noch nicht mal so richtig window, auch wenn man window machen kann, aber, äh,
also linux-desktop ist wirklich grausam, grausam, äh, i3 ist noch das, was ich am ehesten aushalte,
dafür ist i3 echt nice, so, alles ist überstehen geblieben, wir haben geupdated, ssh-gestart,
also, disable automounting, if disk, nein, wurde nicht vorher benutzt, meine disk ist
komplett empty, guck da nix drauf, 20g unbenutzt, become root, haben wir schon, install zfs
in live cd-environment, alles klar, ich copy, wie gesagt, ich mach copy paste hero, copy
paste einfach nur, was die, was die, was die hier schreiben, no install, alles klar, excellent,
fertig jetzt eh installiert, oh nein, oh wie, wie, wie geht, moment, wie geht dieses eine
meme noch mal, ähm, moment, lasst mal kurz überlegen, genau, das war die, oh no, anyway,
ja, als würde es irgendjemand jucken, gell, oh no, wird das system dann auch verwendet,
ne, wahrscheinlich nicht, wie gesagt, ich mach mir das in der vm mal zum ausprobieren,
ich bin mir am überlegen, ob ich nicht irgendwas in der richtung mache, dass ich mein ganzes,
dort da wo ich meine ganzen containers drauflaufen hab, dass ich die einfach mal snapshoten kann,
falls ich upgrade machen will, ich mein natürlich geht es auch anders, aber so ein snapshot
ist manchmal ganz praktisch, snapshot, oh scheiße, kaputt, einfach unmounten, snapshot zurück,
dabei wahrscheinlich muss man euch mal unmounten, na, ist vielleicht nicht verkehrt, einfach,
einfach, docker compose down, snapshot zurück, docker compose up ist wieder da, das hat,
das hat schon was dann, nutzt du docker zum größten teil schon, ja, ah, das ist nice,
das hab ich glaube ich auch bei dieser alten kiste wo ich zfs drauflaufen hatte mal ausprobiert,
da hatte ich aber jetzt nicht allzu viel verwendung für ehrlich gesagt, ich will ja die einzelnen
container will ich ja gar nicht snapshoten oder so, wenn schon, wenn schon würde ich
die komplette disk snapshoten, wo das drauf ist, mal gucken, mal gucken, hab ich mich
noch nicht größer als mit beschäftigt, ne, proxmox mag ich nicht, mein proxmox bringt
ja eh nix großartig für container, du musst dann, also für docker container, du musst
dann da vm machen in der du docker container drauf lassen kannst und das kann ich, kann
ich auch so, ich hab am liebsten ubuntu server drunter, so also was wollen die jetzt hier
von mir, hab ich das, hab ich das jetzt gemacht, jawoll installiert, modprobe, kernel module
laden, alles klar, backports, ich installier alles was ihr wollt, so anscheinend war es
jetzt, so also disk set variable for disk, warum, ok ich mach einfach mal richtig low
brain die anleitung, einfach nur wie es da steht, sonst geht nachher wieder irgendwas
net, def disk by id, da isse, alles klar, was soll ich jetzt machen, disk gleich, na
meinetwegen, wenn die anleitung das sagt, dann machen wir das, oh nein ich hab quotes
drum gemacht, anzeige ist raus, hab ich euch eigentlich schon erzählt, ja ich glaube hab
ich schon 5 mal oder so, nein nicht meine heizungssteuerung, hab ich euch schon erzählt,
wie wir zusammen, wie ich letztens squidlog auswertung optimiert hab, von einer woche
auf 15 minuten runter, oh was da steht was, wegen vm, oh monkaS, are you doing this, äh
benutze kein kvm, ach hier unten fallen wir, was, oh das ist das falsche, guck mal ich hab
mein cd rom, ich hab meine cd gerade hinzugefügt zu disk, na gut fast, oh nee da muss ich neu
starten für, oh nee, come on, nee, ich nehm jetzt einfach sda, alter sda passt schon,
oh disk, ich hab eh nur eine sache drin, die kann nur sda sein, ich müsste neu starten
wenn ich die vmr konfig anpassen will, ne ich mach das jetzt net, hab kein bock da drauf,
je, ds gut ist, und wenns nicht geht hab ich halt gelitten, es gibt ja gar nicht so viele
möglichkeiten was das werden kann außer sda, ich hab ja sonst nix dran, so also weiter,
If you're reusing disk, nein, nein, mache ich nicht, clear partition-dehable
Okay, ist eh nichts drauf, aber
Oh no
Partition your disks, also was, was macht der da, was machen die da für Dinge, das hat mich das letzte Mal auch verwirrt
Vielleicht war irgendjemand damals bei dem Stream noch dabei, schon dabei
Das hat mich, das kann mich dran erinnern, das hat mich das letzte Mal auch verwirrt, da habe ich mich gefragt, was machen die hier eigentlich
Das sind irgendwelche IDs oder so, ne
Also
Ich habe legit keinen Plastenschimmer, was es macht, ich mache das jetzt einfach
Es macht irgendwelche Partitionen, es machte 512 MB, okay, das ist startet
Das ist quasi von vom Start und dann und dann irgendwie 512 MB groß
F00, das ist wahrscheinlich die Partition-ID, denke ich mal, bin mir nicht ganz sicher, keine Ahnung
Nico CS 13 Monate, das ist ja schon massive Hyper-Subscription
Wo habe ich das, die Mode, ich finde es nicht
Danke, danke für den Sub, ah hier
Das ist ein Hexcode, ja, das ist glaube ich die Partitions-ID oder sowas
So, also jetzt haben wir das, das gemacht, ich habe auch es richtig ausgeführt, genau
Bootpool
Ah, der macht
Der macht irgendwie eine Partition für EFI-Boot, eine Partition zum Boot
Oder ein ganz Körnelgeschiss und sowas draufkommt
Das muss doch eigentlich gar kein ZFS sein, das könnte meinetwegen auch
ein XFS oder ein X4 oder irgendwas sein, das muss doch, mein Bootpool muss doch gar kein ZFS sein
Hat auch eigentlich gar keinen großen Vorteil, dass das ZFS ist, oder?
Ich mache es jetzt aber mal trotzdem nach der Anleitung
Es kann auch fast 16
Kann auch fast 16 sein
So, wir machen an der Stelle schon mal einen Snapshot, weil ich weiß, dass ich jetzt gleich irgendwas verkacken werde bestimmt und ich kann bock haben, wieder von vorne anzufangen
So, jetzt haben wir das erstellt, choose one of the following, unencrypted oder native-encryption
Yep, yep cock, weiter
Okay, jetzt haben wir alles erstellt, fdisk minus l
Wir haben eine Partition zum efi-booten, warum haben wir eigentlich 2, 3, 4 und nicht 1, 2, 3?
Na gut, also wir haben den Boot, wir haben den efi, Moment
Jetzt haben wir alles erstellt, weil die hier bei 2 anfangen
Warum fangen die bei efi-boot bei 2 an und bei lag ist die boot bei 1?
Keine Ahnung, ich glaub denen einfach, dass das so sein muss
Yep, yep hab nur ich enabled, yep gibt's nicht für den chat
So, ähm, oh jetzt wird zfl, alter, mehr optionen please
Was ist mit denen los?
Whole birth, meine Güte, klingt aber unanständig, so was machen wir jetzt?
So, ähm, ja passt so, lassen wir mal
Dann createn wir mal den bootpool, ich hab keine Ahnung was es macht, wir machen's einfach
Das liegt daran, weil ich den kram, das ist kein Ding, disk def sda 3, easy geht auch so
Zack, so, you should not need to customize any options, bla bla bla, if you are creating
mirror, nein, wir machen kein mirror, wir machen auch kein raid oder irgendetwas, wir haben einfach
eine platte und gut ist, ja, das system wurde gehole burst, die optionen hören sich teilweise schon
echt kryptisch an, ne, so, ok, create rootpool, ich erinnere mich, a shift 12, das macht man
glaub ich, weil die platten aktuell 4k sektoren haben oder sowas, zfs ist manchmal ein bisschen
kryptisch, ok, native encryption, äh, partition 4, def sda 4, also was machen wir für, was machen wir
für boon, für, für, für optionen, encryption, keyformat pathphrase, wo kann ich denn mein
password jetzt angeben, wahrscheinlich kommt jetzt gleich ne password abfrage, a ja, password,
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, he doesn't know, zfs lacks critical information, 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, huge
password, nice, hat funktioniert, äh, zpool list, zfs list, was war das richtige, das da war das richtige, ok, also
ich hab nen bootpool und nen rootpool, das würd ich glaub ich nicht so machen, wenn ich das, wenn ich
das so verwende, ich würd glaub ich kein bootpool erstellen, wahrscheinlich, wahrscheinlich würd ich
einfach das boot auf den zfs, äh, auf, auf den x4 oder so machen, ich mein wozu, oder braucht man
deswegen encryption, nee, kann eigentlich nicht sein, na gut, machen wir mal weiter, das haben wir
alles gemacht, system installation, create, file system data sets to act as containers, airpool root, airpool boot, alles klar
ja, warum nicht, warum nicht, root, so, jaja, was auf solaris ist, ist mir wurscht, create file system data sets for root and boot file system
machen, mach das jetzt einfach mal, einfach mal brain dead durch zfs mount, ok, bis jetzt funktioniert alles noch, ja
create data, was macht die denn da, ich will doch gar nicht so viele sachen haben, gib mir ein ding für alles und gut ist, kein home, wer braucht denn so was
kann ich nicht einfach ein für alle mount points erstellen, wobei ich muss doch eigentlich gar keine mount points erstellen, oder, das passt doch eigentlich
was, status, nee, list, das reicht doch jetzt eigentlich, mehr muss ich doch eigentlich gar nicht machen, jetzt schreibt er alles auf slash drauf
ok, leute, noch mal kurz einen snapshot machen, falls es jetzt nicht geht, den ganzen anderen crap brauche ich überhaupt nicht, scheiß drauf, das ist das laut den ihrer, äh, whoops
Moment, wurde überstehen geblieben, wo war mal, ja, denn snapshot ist doch auch temporäre dateien, jaja, aber das ist mir jetzt grad vollkommen egal, aber das kann man dann später machen, wenn man das mal ordentlich betreiben will
genau, snapshot auf cache, äh, für die packages ausschalten, für temp ausschalten und sowas, klingt ja eigentlich ganz sinnvoll, aber brauchen wir doch nicht, aber das muss man, nee, Moment, das muss man auch nicht machen
aktuell ist alles angelegt, passt, wir gucken einfach mal, ob es funktioniert, wir benutzen keinen opf, wir benutzen keinen srv, wir benutzen keinen userlocas, ich wissen dich, ja, das ba, snap, gehst sofort, nein, kein gnome
if the system will use docker, which it, which manage its own data sets and snapshots, wisst ihr was, das mach ich jetzt einfach mal, einfach mal zu gucken, was da, was da soll gehen, apparent not present, ach so, weil ich das obere dann mach scheiß drauf, ich lass das jetzt einfach, ich lass das jetzt einfach
mount tempfs at run, ok, mkdir, mount run, tempfs, ich weiß nicht so genau, was ich mache, aber, ah, mkdir, alles klar, but if you want a separate data set for temp9 will ich nicht, install minimal system, ok, debian installation, auf gehts
ok, dann installieren wir mal debian, nice
also snap ist doof, ja, snap suckt, zu snap kann ich bloß sagen, also snap ist so die, weiß nicht, so ne südafrikanische erfindung, ist es ja wirklich
so, jetzt haben wir debian installiert
ok, copy zpool cache, ok, alles klar, keine ahnung was es tut, replace hostname mit desired hostname
gut, chat, hosts editieren, da kann ich mich noch dunkel dran erinnern, da kann ich mich noch dunkel dran erinnern an den kram, den ich hier schonmal, dass ich das schonmal gemacht hab, wartet mal kurz, oh ne, ernsthaft
achso, moin, achso, ich brauch nur ein 0w, was zum, oh nein, es ist ein nackischer vim, ah, please, lass mich in ruhe, ich will wieder raus
use nano if you find vim confusing, ich find vim nicht confusing, vi ohne alles finde ich in der tat confusing, configure network interface, alles klar
name, ens 33, ens 33, auto, ich werd kein nano verwenden chat, so auto, ens 33
warum geht nicht mal cw, alter, was ist das denn, ens 33, hier passt, das ist ja ne sache, die finde ich an debian nice
obuntu macht ja diese komische netplan geschichte mit yaml dateien, da ist mir die konfiguration deutlich lieber
ich hatte auch mal das orally buch für vim 2007 oder so, das war gar nicht so übel um das zu lernen
aber in der heutigen zeit, irgendwelche komischen bücher, null, ich mein internet, google, gut ist, ok, configure package, so, noch einmal
ach nee, jetzt wird es eigentlich das system, ok, weißt du was, so, nein, nein, vim wie ice vielleicht bisschen viel ist gut
also das brauchen wir da jetzt alles, ok, wenn die das sagen, äh, hallo, what the, ihh, da ist maus mode an, deswegen geht das nicht
wer hat denn default mäßig maus modus an, äh, ok, add, zack, ich hab jetzt irgendwas übersehen, sagt mir bescheid chat
wenn ich irgendwas übersehe, was, mnt abt, boah, das ist ja huge kryptisch, keine ahnung was das macht, aber wir machen das jetzt einfach, alles klar
oh nee, maus mode ist wieder aktiviert, zack, stimmt das jetzt was der hier kopiert hat, ja, tatsächlich, achso, das ist mit zeilenumbruch hier drin, package, äh, das ist irgendeine abt magic
ist das das da die pakete nicht updated oder sowas, ey, das würd ich nie, das würd ich so nie auf meinem server installieren, das weiß ich ja
ich verhalte mir nicht mehr wie es funktioniert, ok, oh jetzt kommt, jetzt kommt big brain magic, ok, also, bind, def, proc, sys, temp, mkt, das haben wir doch vorhin schon gemacht
nö, jetzt wieder weg, was ist genau die anleitung, wie man nen debian aufm zfs installiert und davon bootet inklusive die native verschlüsselung von zfs verwendet
disk ist, what, what, what, def str, zack, sind wir reingewechselt in das zu unser zukünftiges system, so, config a basic system environment, alles klar
updateen, ok, das ist aber echt die hardcore manuell variante hier, if you prefer non-english system language, nein, ich will nur, please, kein englische tastatur
aber german, german no dead keys, nein, nein, nein, einfach nur german no dead keys, ja, utf8, alles wunderbar, exellent
ok, hat wahrscheinlich funktioniert, install zfs, achja, jetzt muss ich das nochmal installieren, dass es das ganze zfs zeug hat, wenn ich reboote
das vorhin war ja nur auf der live cd, uwe kubikmeter, das ist irgendeine 80 minuten nostalgik, nostalgik, nintendo v games music mix
ohje, leute, ich muss mal ganz kurz afk
ich muss mal ganz kurz afk
ok
massiv auf den sack geht
Bei ubuntu ist die geschichte mit netplan also netplan ist wirklich crap
Das wird weder noch das wird noch vm die wird danach wieder gelöscht
Also jetzt machen wir das was auch immer uns das sagt also irgendwie module neue led
beim
Genöns erstellen vermute ich mal ich habe keine ahnung
Drei monat lang schon mit ins ab
excellent subscription
Obwohl das ist noch nicht hyper subschreiber hyper subscribers am 12 monate
Es wird übrigens mal zeit dass ich ein paar badges mache oder machen lasse je nachdem ich
Weil jetzt haben wir schon ein paar emotes jetzt haben wir immerhin die hälfte aller emotes slots voll
wenn überhaupt wie viele maus habe ich denn
1 2 3
11 12 ja die hälfte ungefähr die emotes slots ist knapp die hälfte voll
ein paar subschreiber erschlichen ja bann ist raus direkt beim
subscribt dann gebannt
Leute hat jemand eine ahnung was ist wenn man subscribt und direkt gebannt wird kriegt man dann kriegt man das dann erstattet
Weil es wäre ja schon fies
Können wir eine wette machen er muss schon was überlegen kriegt man nicht
Ok moment was machen wir das muss man gar nicht machen hier
install krabb ok jetzt jetzt wird es ernst install krabb uefi booting
ab install dos fs tools alles klar machen wir
und gucken dass ich nix übersehen habe oder
es sieht gut aus sieht gut aus
Mk dos fs was auch immer
Das das funktioniert so nicht def sda 2 ist das Richtige
Aber wir machen irgendwelche efe verzeichnete dass er dann gleich booten kann
Und jetzt muss ich das wieder anpassen dass der jetzt hätte ich das mal ordentlich gemacht
Def
sda 2
so und jetzt nach in die fs tab schreiben
Ok hat funktioniert guck mal was da drin steht fs tab
Alles echt funktioniert
Und funktioniert liste dann ist alles gut
Die uid wird ändert sich hoffentlich auch nicht
Deswegen ist ja nie
So also jetzt haben wir den kram installiert ich mache jetzt noch mal einen snapshot weil es kann immer noch was schief gehen
Take snapshot muss ich das mal aufstehen
Also jetzt haben wir den kram installiert ich mache jetzt noch mal einen snapshot weil es kann immer noch was schief gehen
Take snapshot muss ich dann da übrigens alles wieder löschen hat immer allzu viel plattenplatz guckt euch das mal an hier
Ich bin am limit leute am limit
wird knapp
10 g auf c
Warum habe ich noch 10 g auf c wait
Ich habe es so alles auf e oder gehen snapshots immer immer auf auf c
hoffe ja nicht
Was bei meinem arbeitgeber wurden bis vor kurzem noch extrem viele forms mit suzé 9
Ja so ich suzé mag ich überhaupt nicht das also suzé gefällt mir wirklich gar nicht
Das soll ich mounten und jetzt soll ich group installieren mal gucken ob das jetzt funktioniert
Remove os prober ok alles klar set root password ja klar 1 2 3 4 5 6 1 2 3 4 5 6 alles klar
Aber das hat doch gar kein krab installiert das hat doch gar kein krab installiert das hat doch gar kein krab installiert
Aber das hat doch gar kein krab installiert oder hat das hier krab mit ins ach so ja krab installiert aber wir haben doch kein kein wir haben es noch nicht auf die platte geschrieben
So enabling importing b pool
Eier ok
Nicht dass ich genau durchblicken würde was das ist ich habe mir das nicht so gut ausgesucht
Ok nicht dass ich genau durchblicken würde was es da tut aber wir machen das jetzt einfach mal
Super ja bei suzé ist es super oder die old school leute mit jast wobei die sache ist halt die jast war mal cool vor 20 jahren
Mittlerweile ist es irgend so ein verkorkstes ding keine ahnung
Ok was macht das unit file
Ok
Gedeun importieren
Alles klar
Optional mount attempt fs to temp
Alles klar mache ich user share system d temp mount temp
Wenn es recommended ist machen wir das einfach mal install popcon nein
Krab installation ok verify dass fs boot file system ist recognize krab brod boob nicht boob
Boots Refresh in the files. Ja mal gucken ob es funktioniert
Kämmer das geht aber glaube ich an ein paar allem oder dieses live kernel update das ist auch nicht
Ehm nicht nicht 100% ich das das hat eigenheiten wo es nicht geht das geht nur in speziellen fällen
So er hat ein boot image erstellt ok passt workaround krab's missing zpool feature support
Was was wollen die von mir das doch auskommentiert
Das das das check ich jetzt net was wollen die von mir
Ich meine wenn ich das auskommentiert da reinschreibe wird das wohl kaum was bringen
Ach nee die wollen dass ich die zeile einfach so hin so setze ok
Also so das hätte man auch ein bisschen schöner schreiben können
Ok
Ok make debugging krab easier remove quiet das hab ich schon entfernt nee hab ich net zack krabba net
Uncomment krab terminal
Ups hab ich
Hab ich ok update krab konfiguration
Alles klar aus die musik fertig ups exzellent nochmal neu starten
So alles funktioniert update krab haben wir gemacht oder haben wir es gemacht
dann machen wir es einfach nochmal ich hatte ja nichts so install bootloader legacy bios
install uefi bootloader krab install x86 efi boot efi bootloader debian no floppy
oh schwierige entscheidungen so floppy wäre schon nicht schlecht
ok no error reported sehr gut fix file system mounting order
eine gute ey das ist ja eine wissenschaft für sich
a separate mount points ok ich mach einfach ich mach einfach was die typen was die
typen mir vorschlagen
ok getouched
alles klar ich oh nein file exist
ok ist es jetzt schlecht
ich weiß eh nicht was es macht wenn ich ehrlich bin
und macht das jetzt was
guck mal mal was es macht
es macht dinger ok
der scheiß norm ach man muss das im background machen das wird gar nicht fertig oder was ach so
boah das ist das ist echt big brain hier
ah not empty not empty auch not empty
ok also passt alles hat alles funktioniert sehr gut fix the pass
ich copy paste einfach nur noch alles gut ok install open ssh auf jeden fall
dass das linke was gefällt ist ja das ist eine gute idee also
ach so moment hier ist wie ist das hier history
site of user lip zfs zf ich würd sagen das passt
die sieht eigentlich gut aus
so permit root login yes
exit ok ich glaube es wird ernstloy ich glaube es wird ernst ok machen wir alles klar reboot
ok mal gucken und und und enter passphrase 12345678 es funktioniert
ok so jetzt gehen wir mal auf ein anderes system 65 also moment wir müssen mal kurz
wir müssen mal kurz die netzwerkarte umstöpseln dass ich eine ordentliche ip krieg bricht
ok 12345678 gutberg wäre stolz du meinst weil ich so gut kopiert hab ja nice das muss
ich mir merken der ist gut wenn eine ordentlich copy paste das sag ich jetzt auch gutenberg
wäre stolz das hat was 2128 ok ssh 2.128 ach so gut gut tut gut 12345678 zack update
sind wir am start so dann kopieren wir mal die anleitung noch mal rüber wait da und
machen noch die restlichen schritte irgendwas fehlt da bestimmt noch morgen nehme ich das
video auf mit dem shit repo azumi schon überlegt ok first boot sind wir jetzt haben wir gemacht
sie eingeloggt reboot create user account die man das alles als root warum soll ich
einen neuen user anlegen lull er braucht dann schon etwas anderes als root user also mal
ernsthaft jetzt overrated gebated einfach alles als root machen nie wieder rechte probleme
haben das machen wir nicht das machen wir nicht was if you nein ob ob konfigure konfigure
swap ja chrome mag auch nicht laufen auf root da muss man die sendbox ausschalten vincent
hanna mit prime dankeschön für den sub massive subscription iq plus plus für den chat hier
platz gleich so also das machen wir nicht swap prominent overrated ich meine wir haben immer
hin 4g muss reichen full software installation ok upgrade to minimal system ja ja ja minimal
demian minimal system ist durchaus in ordnung ja gut wir haben schon ssh installiert wir
müssen eigentlich nichts nicht brauchen wir eigentlich nichts ne ssh server ist schon
drauf und jetzt eigentlich alles in ordnung ja gut da kann ich jetzt ja die snapshots
wieder wieder löschen in der hoffnung dann wird meine festplatte ein bisschen mehr frei
warum habe ich noch 10,5 warum ist das so groß auf einmal aber im moment falsche falsche
vm snapshot manager damit oh das wusste ich auch nicht dass das geht man kann drei snapshots
auf einmal löschen poggers geht drei stunden später
leute hat jemand von euch tas motor auf einer steckdose installiert und hat mit der 9 9.3
auch probleme dass es massive langsam ist das webinterface nach dem update ok jetzt
kommen wieder die normalos die sagen wie was habe ich installiert auf meiner steckdose
keck weight ja aber ich meine als ernsthaft was auf der steckdose installiert und seit
seit neun drei kam vorgestern raus oder so ja leute ich sehe es genauso wie du leute
die ihre steckdose nichts nicht flaschen nobbi's
ja da kam nämlich gestern jetzt aber vorher ist es ganz neu ja sieben ok vor sieben tagen
version 9 5 9.3 und angeblich ist da irgendwie ein bisschen verbesserte home assistant support
oder irgendwas dabei habe ich gelesen deswegen wollte es updaten und seitdem ist das webinterface
ultra langsam bei der einsteckdose ich auch die einzige mit der ich es ausprobiert habe
wo ist denn die überhaupt wo habe ich denn die hin keck weight wo sind die dass die
hier steht moment ich muss die irgendwo hin haben ich hatte die vorhin in der hand verwirrungsstelle
ich habe die bestimmt in mann serverraum hinten gelegt
ich wollte jetzt eigentlich nur mal schnell anstöpseln und gucken ob die jetzt geht wo
habe ich denn die hin ist die das doch hier die steckdose ist weiß und steckt in der
anderen weißen steckdose deswegen habe ich sie nicht gesehen die war die ganze zeit dran
schon gucken wir mal mal gucken ob das tas motor zeug sich jetzt wieder gefangen hat
60 punkt 108 hat die glaube ich gekriegt
danke für den zap ich doch da ist er guck mal aber die hat die settings wieder vergessen
die hat die hat die settings vergessen gucken das webinterface ist übelst lahm geworden
690 danke für den zap guck mal seht ihr das wie kacke lahm das webinterface ist voll
im arsch seit dem update die steckdose
ich hab für die wichtigen sachen dns von mir am start diese steckdosen die hab die steuer
ich über meine über meine über mein home assistant da da brauche ich keine dns alias
weil da heißen die geräte halt arbeitsarbeitszimmer schreibtisch oder so guck mal was ist mit
dem webinterface das kann natürlich ernst sein hier seht ihr das kacke weight und außerdem
hat es irgendwie die jetzt jetzt hat er reloaded hat er das gesehen wie lange das gedauert
hat ja guck mal das webinterface von meiner steckdose ist langsam ja ist aber so so und
die settings hat er sich auch nicht gemerkt ja das ist die steckdose das da doch normalerweise
muss man das hier reinkopieren guck mal der lädt immer noch was ist das denn wie lahm
das ist max auf twitch ja schon seit drei jahren oder so aber ich hab es nie so selten
an die große glocke gehängt ja guck mal das lädt einfach nicht massive lahm ja ja
ferngesteuerte steckdose smarte steckdosen zum beispiel ein anwendungszweck wofür das
richtig cool ist du siehst hier mein 3d drucker und ich kann den automatisch ausschalten lassen
wenn der druck zu ende ist das ist praktisch der scheiß braucht ordentlich strom ja druck
zu enden warte ich noch fünf minuten nachdem der timer aus ist schalte ich ihn automatisch
aus über die steckdose also dafür wollte ich die steckdose guck mal die lädt immer
noch das seit ich geupdatet hab auf 9.3 ist das ding absolut unusable ist doch der witz
ja und und wenn man pinkt witzigerweise ist kein problem naja ok schwankte bissl macht
die alte firme doch wieder drauf ja wenn ich mal überhaupt bis dahin kommen würde
dann könnte ich das machen ich das mal an hier kannst du voll vergessen schreiker das
ist das falsche leider da geht kein ssh da ist ja kein lielungs drauf wann kommt der
weihnachtskacke wieder weg also ich würde sagen an weihnachten weil ich das ehrlich
gesagt ziemlich cool finde dass ich als einziger den weihnachtskacke habe oder soll ich den
weg machen chat ihr könnt euch aussuchen ich finde cool dass der weihnachtskacke noch
da ist also wie ihr wollt wenn ihr den weg haben wollt wir machen eine umfrage wir machen
eine umfrage
liches kacke nee wir machen eine umfrage soll soll der weihnachten kacke weg und wieder
der normale hin ja nein dauer zwei minuten werden weg oder bleiben fragezeichen behalten
kacke normalen kacke wieder rein machen umfrage beginnen so bin ich mal gespannt ich bin
auch dafür den zu behalten der chat auch sehr schön wird ihr öfters gestreben ja guckt
doch mal in die history ich war glaub die letzten drei von vier tagen und oder so es
kann sein dass das wort vom sonntag nicht da ist weil dann habe ich auf aliexpress aus
versehen ein oder es war wirklich aus versehen ich weiß jetzt doof an einen besonders lebensnahen
dildo gezeigt aus versehen auf aliexpress und habe ich mir gedacht ich lösche das mal
wer weiß was twitch dazu sagt das war ein wurde einfach so empfohlen das wurde einfach
auf ohne scheiß ich war bei aliexpress ich habe ich weiß gar nicht was ich auf aliexpress
gezeigt habe nichts was damit zu tun hatte ich glaube wir haben uns im fertig haus auf
aliexpress angeguckt fertig haus auf aliexpress auf einmal kommt da unten so ein komischer
jeb cock jeb jeb cock aus silikon kam dann auf einmal unten in der in der empfehlung
i need coke cola cola kennt ihr noch jemand das sind so old school meme videos die kennt
heute keiner mehr doch klar ok coke please give me coke cola ok kennt man ja kann man
und es gibt sogar ein komplettes security research projekt was sich mit exploits von
6 tools beschäftigt toys nicht tools beschäftigt und es gibt sogar ein open source projekt
es gibt sogar ein open source projekt für den open source buttplug ich habe schon wieder
vergessen wie dieses projekt heißt das hat einen richtig geilen namen so richtig wo nur
irgendwelche hacker leute drauf kommen können 69 jawoll ok der weihnachtskeck weh bleibt
leute alles klar weihnachtskeck weh easy so
moment ich muss mal kurz gucken wie das hieß heise bei heise stand das irgendwie
keine ahnung ist auch egal wie das ding heißt genau buttplug.io war das eine nee es gab
irgendwie so ein security projekt es hat einen richtig geilen namen aber dass es sowas
gibt und ja man kann das flaschen man kann das flaschen welche distro das ist man schau
mit die 3wm so hat es jetzt ok ok firmen upgrade guck mal ich kann doch nicht mal das alte
mit mehr flaschen so lahm ist der scheiß das ist doch nicht normal ok ich downgrade jetzt
einfach releases releases wo ist das alte by the way das hat mit zfs gar nichts zu tun
wo man nur so fällt mir nur grad so ein dass ich meine steckdose mal wieder flaschen muss
das motor bin minimal muss man downloaden aber wir flaschen dass ich flascht das jetzt
schnell dass man steckdose wieder geht das motor minimal flaschen upgrade auf gehts zerstört
max mit dem downgrade seine steckdose nee das müssen wir nicht wetten die geht nicht
kaputt weil wenn die kaputt gehen würde müsste ich sie aufschreiben aufschrauben
und ich kann die nicht mehr aufschrauben weil ich hab die mit heißkleber wieder zu gemacht
also wenn ich die jetzt pricke doch wetten please ok wie wettet man denn jetzt müsst
ihr mir sagen ich weiß nicht wie das geht noch noch kann da nichts passieren noch ist
die minimalfirma um frage nee konnte man nicht twitch bet points moment wie wettet man punten
punkte predictions jahu ich will doch nicht von jahu mir beibringen lassen wie das funktioniert
ok leute wie geht das mod check mod check ich brauch help helft mir was ich weiß nicht
wie das geht slash bet nee ok das geht nicht ne das muss man und 3d what
das muss man einrichten tier für streamer jaja um frage wetten ok leute hab keine ahne
wie das geht ich hab legit eine umfrage vorschlagen kann man machen ok twitch vorhersage ok also
zeig her twitch wie geht das wie geht das wie starte ich eine vorhersage creator mod
steam prediction slash prediction slash prediction ok ich gebe euch zwei minuten zeit dann mache
ich jetzt das update dann sehen wir ob es geprägt wird wobei nee moment eine minute
eine minute also um frage benennen macht max mit dem downgrade seine steckdose kaputt
frage zeichen ergebnis ja ergebnis nein vorhersage starten oh ich hab zu viel
macht das downgrade die steckdose kaputt frage zeichen vorhersage starten vorhersage bestätigen
du oder ein mod muss das ergebnis innerhalb von 24 stunden nach dem ende der einrichtungsfrist
der vorhersage bestätigen ok verstanden äh äh übrigens glücksspiel kann süchtig
machen erst ab 18 disclaimer auf die schnelle ok wie ich sehe nicht ich sehe nicht wie viel
zu wie viel es steht alter was habt ihr alles für channel points ok das muss nein sein
du musst auf predict klicken ja nee jetzt vorbei ich sehe es ich sehe es ja immer noch
bei mir so und wie und wie bestätige ich das jetzt sie ist jetzt weg Leute habt ihr
die channel points wieder bekommen die die ist weg die umfrage wie moment woher weiß
ich denn jetzt ob die fack war jetzt hier gerade die sache mit dem mit dem mit dem twitch
prediction ok also meine leute ich muss mir das jetzt erst mal angucken wie das funktioniert
ich habe keine ahnung dashboard ach du siehst die jetzt captain zieke das heißt die moch
und die meint das heißt die mods können das auch be captain peng kannst du mal ein
paar die im dashboard gucken ob du das jetzt bestätigen kannst dann ok ok ich trage jetzt
erst mal also ich habe jetzt also was jetzt gemacht habe ich folgendes ich habe auf 9
3 minimal firmen wir umgestellt das ist kein problem das geht eigentlich immer auf minimal
firmen wir umstellen das problem ist das downgrade auf eine version und der typ schreibt sogar
das hätte ich vielleicht vorher sagen sollen ich glaube der typ schreibt sogar dass ab
dieser version downgrades nicht mehr supportet werden
also also schauen wir mal dann uploaden wir jetzt wir haben jetzt 9.1 tas motor binn kommen
wir downloaden das geht zepte upgrade starten ok also auf gehts probieren wir mal also wohl
gemerkt geprickt also booten denke ich wird es auf jeden fall aber es zählt erst als
erfolgreich wenn es booted und ordentlich funktioniert also wenn ich dann auch was wenn
ich dann auch was was mit machen kann also wenn die wenn die danach nicht mehr schaltet
dann ist die geprickt auch wenn sie bootet ja ok start upgrade
ok successful schon mal gut
das heißt noch gar nichts ja das braucht ein bisschen da ist sie wieder
es geht nicht ok schaltet es schaltet nix also kann das ding auch strom messen die nicht
die nicht aber die anderen die ich hab moment warum heißt es noch basic module sollte das
nicht anders heißen ah die weiß nehmen die anderen gibt es gar nicht mehr ich muss noch
mal restarten die weißen wie habe ich das andere ding genannt habe ich beides oder so
egal ich speicher jetzt wir gucken jetzt einfach funktioniert so also wenn ihr jetzt booted
und jetzt schaltet dann funktioniert die vorhersage ist nein ich glaube die vorhersage
ist auch richtig also ja es schaltet klick klick klick klick wir haben es nicht geprickt
den inner nein ich bin froh dass es nicht geprickt ist und
der kram läuft doch wieder schnell ja guck mal 93 ohne scheiß 93 ist das problem guck
mal wie schnell 91 läuft habt ihr gesehen wie wie 93 rumgeleckt hat eats 2k verdient
ja hier fast besser wie bei gamestop und jetzt kann ich die zwischen meinen 3d trocker
stöpseln den 3d trocker damit an und ausschalten so das ist bei dabei aber überhaupt nicht
das wofür wir da sind eigentlich wollten wir was muss man zfs mäßig jetzt noch machen
final clean up aber nicht gut passwort lass ich ich habe eh nur gut was du hier sollst
ganz ohne channel points in ja neue channel points sammeln was sonst es gibt übrigens
ein nice plugin leute wie heißt es denn auto channel points gibt es ein nice nice auto
claim ja ich weiß nicht welches davon ist der macht es für euch automatisch ach echt
ffz kann das mittlerweile auch das ist cool wirklich ffz nach was muss ich untersuchen
points kyoko 19 monate nice dankeschön für den sub das ist natürlich hypersubscription
hier kann man das nicht machen oder braucht man dafür den extra ffz addon du musst zu
den addons ok ok ok smoky utilities was macht das
ja ist ja geil steht ihr steht ja sehr viel da
ok ich aktiviere das jetzt einfach mal gucken wir mal schnell smoky enable settings es gibt
ja keine settings dafür jetzt points ah hier auto point claimer oh nice easy siehst du
leute einfach gucken und automatisch points claimen so geht das so ist das nice easy das
brauma ich meine hier disable ich setze wieder weil ich bin ich nicht mal eingeloggt easy
um nicht zu sagen
wisst ihr was noch die nächste weiß wisst ihr was noch mehr next level wäre wenn man
nicht da ist einfach auf dem server twitch mit headless chrome laufen lassen geht bestimmt
irgendwie und dort ein auto claim also 24 7 channel points cram ohne dass man guckt
und und das dann auch bei 100 streams und dann hat man dann ist mal channel point milliardär
soll jetzt mal schnell gucken wir sind durch glaube ich mit der standardsache soll jetzt
ist die frage wie schaffe ich das dass ich automatisch anlocken install ab auto complete
debian das ist erst mal das allerwichtigste wie mache ich autocomplete und dem und debian
also einfach nur best completion installiert das sehr easy da wäre ich jetzt hätte ich
gedacht dass es einfach ist tatsächlich ab install job hier also ich versuche jetzt
noch mal dass man den kram per ssh anlocken kann aber wahrscheinlich werde ich das nicht
hinbekommen ja wir haben gerade gewettet der krypte da brauche ich ja nicht oh ne das kriege
ich das kriege ich da mal gebacken da muss ich muss bei meinem eigenen stream abgucken
wie haben wir das das letzte mal gemacht einfach stream von vor drei jahren gucken da haben
wir das nämlich irgendwann schon mal gemacht max was machst du da hier permit root ok
max was hast du vor drei jahren gemacht ich habe es irgendwie hingekriegt anscheinend
ich habe ich habe es irgendwie hingekriegt ich habe am besten mit kein plan mehr wie
guck mal ey leute wenn ich es vor drei jahren schon hingekriegt habe easy
nicht mit zertifikat nicht mit zertifikat mit passphrase habe ich das
vor drei jahren gekriegt ich habe den extra skript gebastelt oh ne da habe ich schon da
bin ich zu müde für jetzt das krieg ich nicht mehr nicht mehr hin
ok nfs ja das das das weiß wie es funktioniert was man was habe ich damals gemacht dass das
ganze system ist verschlüsselt authorized keys jaja passt schon max ok kommt jetzt schon
abfrage wenn ich neu starte was muss man machen kino minus k minus u all oder so anikar all
muss man machen infolet authorized keyfile emote unlocking will not work ja das ist mir
erstmal wurscht ich will jetzt erstmal gucken ob das prinzipiell da überhaupt reingeht
ja ich weiß wie das funktioniert ich will nur gucken ob der jetzt überhaupt was macht
ok ok da würde den netboot achso ne da hat sich jetzt nur vom dhcp was geholt 2128 ok
der server ist gestartet anscheinend gut da muss ich jetzt noch ein ssh key reinschmeißen
mal gucken wir mal wie ging das nochmal etc in it nee authorized keys und da muss ich
hier mein authorized keys und da muss ich mein ssh login rein machen ne cut ssh id rsa pup
maxed poggers ja genau so mag ich das da sieht man gleich das muss ein ssh key von mir sein
ich erkenne auf der arbeit auch immer sofort meine ssh keys weil die haben immer so dofe
comments da weiß ich gleich das es meiner ist ok du kannst den key abschreiben das
ist ein public key da bringt dir gar nichts der aktiviert das netzwerk dass er von irgendwo
den key herbekommt ja normalerweise macht er das auch komplett automatisch aber ich
glaube zfs können die standardmäßig nicht ok reboot schauen wir mal ob es zumindest
bis zum login funktioniert weil extra script basteln wie letztes mal hab ich keinen bock
drauf da bin ich zu müde für ok der startet den kram ja ist gut options no strict tosky
hacking no no da sind wir crypt root unlock ob das funktioniert nee das hätte mich auch
gewundert das ist das geht nur für lux z ja das ganze zfs zeug ist dann was ist das
zfs unlock wait a minute ist das etwa alles schon dabei ich muss gar nichts mehr machen
easy das hätte ich jetzt nicht gedacht das hätte ich jetzt nicht gedacht ok das ist
wirklich easy zack ja nice ja das ist ok das ist definitiv einfacher muss man kurz den
hacker modus aktivieren das ist definitiv einfacher als vor drei jahren vor drei jahren
muss ja noch ein eigenes kripp zusammenwursten ich checker mode wieder an hier das ist ja
das ist wirklich nicht schwer also hätten die das jetzt bei opunto surfer ordentlich
integriert dass man beispielsweise das im installer auswählen kann dann würde ich verwenden
auf diese zeremonien in server auf root zu instillen habe ich keinen bock genau also
pt bier pt bier so wie ich das verstehe kann aber ich kann aber riebungen so wie ich das
verstehe hat der einen ssh server in sein image in sein boot image rein gemacht dann
der startet das netzwerk starten ssh server dann musste ich mich einloggen per key authentifizierung
weil ich den vorher über hinterlegt habe und dort konnte ich dann das password eingeben
und nachdem das password eingegeben wurde hat er das laufwerk unlockt und dann den boot
weiter eingestoßen wir können ja da mal reingucken was das macht hier zfs unlock gucken wir mal
rein ist bestimmt normales shell script ja also guck mal nicht mal sondern nicht lang
das macht ja mit lux images funktioniert das schon lange das benutze ich seit jahren auf
irgendwelchen serven oder sonst wo das verschlüsselt sein muss mit lux funktioniert das schon richtig
lang ich wusste nicht dass mit zfs auch funktioniert ok aber das ist auch gar nicht sonderlich
lang dass das dieses besting was macht denn das geblabla blabla ist glaube ich auch ziemlich
egal genau oder macht eine schleife solange es nicht unlockt ist dann fragt ja das password
ab würde ich mal sagen das ist das kommando zum password abfragen hier wird das password
abgefragt das hier ist der name vom filesystem genau der pipe das dann nach load key load
key ist wahrscheinlich das ding zum entsperren chopper ist ein minimaler ssh server der ist
schon dabei könnte man prud forsten wie lang brauchst du für 12345678 um das zu prud forsten
das klingt das kann man ja von hand prud forsten was der hacker man 12345678 hast du
ganz schnell so das ist nice das gefällt mir dass das so easy funktioniert hat was
macht eigentlich der speicherplatz auf meiner festplatte aber immer noch warum ist das so
klein wartet mal kurz download debian live oh ich habe da noch eine windows iso drauf
keck wait warte mal debian weg windows iso weg office 2000 warum zum ach für den windows
xp stels den wir mal gemacht haben falls ich noch der eine oder andere erinnert wir haben
noch windows xp stels gemacht dafür habe ich das gebraucht windows 2000 wenn es die alten
versionen hiervon brauchen wir nicht mehr mal gucken alles wieder löschen das war mal
kurz bis sie platz ok 20g bisschen bisschen mehr platz wieder nice sehr sehr schön das
gefällt mir richtig gut also der instas install ist noch ein bisschen kompliziert aber ich
sag mal so wenn die wirklich in im nächsten also spätestens also ich hoffe mal darauf
dass spätestens in der nächsten ubuntu lts also sprich das wäre dann nächstes jahr
april stimmt das ubuntu lts schedule auf jubanto geoff auch so haben die noch gar nicht
drin stehen also es müsste dann 22 04 müsste das nächste lts sein hier ja ja genau das
nächste also ich hoffe mal dass sie es hinbekommen dass spätestens bis 22 04 zfs mit encryption
im installer drin ist das wäre cool weil ansonsten ist alles ist alles nice und ist alles nicht
sonderlich schwierig aber diese also auf diese zeremonie hätte ich keinen bock jedes mal
wenn ich ein system zu ins installiere diese zeremonie hier zu machen das ist mir zu zu
doof ja dann dann dann lieber die folgen ist im installer es ist im installer drin aber
es ist im installer nicht für server os drinne und es ist im installer experimental und es
ist keine encryption drinne also im prinzip das was ich haben will aber es ist eine coole
sache ok jetzt haben wir den kram docker docker macht angeblich eigene zfs snapshots stand
da irgendwo das probieren wir doch jetzt einfach mal aus ich kann sagen so ist es installiert
ne ab install ok ja wir machen jetzt einfach mal in den debian container debian container
im debian container und dann gucke ich mal ob das eigene sachen macht die docker rand
und wie geht das debian beschnee wie ging das noch mal das krieg ich aus dem kopf immer
ja chopper ist poggers docker rand debian besch ich habe es fast richtig ich habe es
fast richtig fast richtig ok da war es docker ran wir machen es was anderes ubuntu musste
man minus rm machen dass es danach wieder löscht ach nee moment wir sind schon drinne
es hat doch funktioniert es hat doch funktioniert lull nice aber debian in debian am laufen
noch mal upgraden debian in debian so und jetzt gucken wir mal und jetzt hat und jetzt
hat das eigene docker image ein eigenes zfs angelegt nee oder ist das hier sind das hier
die docker images könnte sein ne probieren wir mal aus docker rm ah jetzt sind sie weg
jetzt noch das image da tatsächlich docker macht eigene zfs data sets ok docker rmi debian
latest jetzt alles weg ok und was genau lasst mal überlegen was genau bringt mir das jetzt
ich meine ich könnte die snap schotten aber eigentlich will ich das gar nicht nee so
wirklich bringen tut mir das jetzt eigentlich gar nichts wenn ich ehrlich bin was viel cooler
wäre wenn ich ein komplettes wenn ich das war lip docker wenn ich das komplette war
lip docker auf zfs kriegen würde weil weil das coole wäre dann könnte ich echt in docker
compose file machen und und ich würde einfach einen snapshot machen von dem kompletten
war lip docker dann würde ich ein update machen und wenn das nicht funktioniert dann also
mal angenommen ich hätte den war ich hätte den docker compose file wo alles auf latest
steht so und dann mache ich den update und wenn das nicht funktioniert mache ich einfach
den snapshot zurück und es geht wieder das wäre eigentlich cool der desktop ist massive
pocket ja ich nehme das ist der grund warum ich kein latest tech nehmen aber man könnte
den latest tech nehmen und einfach vorher snapshot machen dann würde ich den dann würde ich
das nämlich alles auf eine platte packen mein compose file das docker zeug und alles und
dann snapshot wenn es nicht geht einfach snapshot zurück vorher doch komposed down und dann
snapshot zurück das müsste auch klappen pock muss mir mal Gedanken drüber machen aber
ich bin schon mal begeistert wie nice das funktioniert es ist es ist alles gut integriert
bis auf das set up das set up sagt ein bisschen ja aber ansonsten es funktioniert alles out
of the box ja genau extrem techniker so ungefähr habe ich mir das gedacht und jetzt zfs unlock
1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 bam unlock lock mich aus und jetzt aufs root einloggen das ist schon cool
das ist nice also das funktioniert easy nun ist manuelles set up nervt mich ein bisschen
ich muss mir mal internet von 1995 angucken jetzt eine runde blizzard von
1995 so sah battle net 1995 aus ich kann mich da noch dran erinnern als diablo als
diablo 1 online gespielt haben mit modem da sah das ungefähr so kacke aus wie es jetzt
aussieht ja die warcraft 1 demo nintendo.com wie sah nintendo.com 1996 aus wahrscheinlich
genauso wie heute bei nintendo weiß man nie oh ne grip nintendo will nicht wikipedia 1996
das funktioniert irgendwie grad nix warum ist das so kaputt
icq guck mal die weeps waren damals schon am start seht ihr das so sah wikipedia 1996
aus ja sogar 1996 waren sie schon am start das mach ich jetzt lieber nicht auf uns komm
noch irgendwelche tentakel oder so das ist nicht kaputt das hat so lange gedauert ach
du meinst es ist die original die original experience die auch das laden simuliert übrigens
damals war es normal dass die seiten weiß war ne dark theme hat da keiner dran gedacht
aber ich kanns mal machen dass ihr nicht blind werdet dark theme ich weiß gar nicht ob
man damals überhaupt background setzen konnte in html schon
download den internet explorer unbedingt natürlich guck mal die finale version für internet explorer
2 endlich das rainbow gift du meinst das da das rainbow gift war angesagt kennt ihr noch
dieses gift von dem typ von so ne rennanimation von so nem dude der so gerannt ist das hatte
man auch so schnell ins gästebuch und hat man so nen renntyp gemacht und sowas und wisst
ihr was ich ja total verstörend finde 1996 waren gift der neueste scheiß und 2021 sind
gift immer noch voll angesagt ich mein gifts oder wie die coolen leute sagen gifs hätte
mir einer ohne mist hätte mir einer 1996 gesagt 2021 verwenden die leute mehr gifts
als jemals zuvor das hätt ich dem nicht geglaubt und wenn einer gesagt hätte gifs hätt ich
ihn damals schon ausgelacht hat er hat er noch kann man ja irgendwie suchen Twitter gabs 1996
doch noch gar nicht so alt ist twitter auch nicht
ach das ist ah guck mal das ist wikipedia auf alt gemacht aber es ist nicht wirklich auf
es ist nicht wirklich alt aber genau so scheiße sahen damals die webseiten aus ok
ja 1997 guck mal da versagt sogar da versagt sogar der dark reader bei dieser seite
das hat eigentlich gemacht dass sie so abgekackt sind war richtig gut
flashbang der dark reader funktioniert hier nicht jetzt doch keine gratis zudem ja ich
hatte damals aol hatte ich angemeldet über meine mutter und über mein opa und über
mein vater und dann bin ich drauf reingefallen die ultima online beta ok das ist ein und
dann sind wir teilweise drauf reingefallen dass man es rechtzeitig kündigen muss die
haben gerade die ww seite von origin gefunden interactive demos wing commander 1995 oh man
ja und dass sie das hier die das encoding nicht richtig funktioniert hat das war ja
auch normal webseiten encoding war schon immer kaputt spielst du noch overwatch nee schon
war kein ja nicht mehr würde sogar sagen mittlerweile mehr mal heckermode anmachen
nee nee nee habe ich auch nicht mehr vor und ich glaube auch nicht dass overwatch 2 irgendwas
reißen wird also die blitzkonne war ja echt enttäuschend ich habe letztens gegrinscht
ich habe ich habe mittag gegessen habe radio angemacht und dann kam so ein typ im radio
und meinte er erzählt uns jetzt irgendwie 20 facts 20 facts über das internet oder
habe ich da habe ich schon habe ich schon aufgehorscht und ich dachte mir schon dass
wird pains camp und es wurde pains camp er hat unter anderem erzählt dass die 404 fehlermeldung
daher kommt weil im zern der raum mit den servan 404 drauf stand also das denken viele
weil irgendwelche leute mal angefangen haben das zu verbreiten also das habt ihr bestimmt
auch schon gehört diese sache dass es angeblich so wäre aber das hat das stimmt nicht das
ist nicht so also das gerücht gibt schon ganz lange aber das ist nicht so das hat damit
überhaupt nichts zu tun es war echt es war echt zum grinsen wusste nicht dass es vom
zern kommt doch kommt vom zern also nicht das internet sondern htp und web browsing geschichten
kommt daher nein das hat mit dem das hat mit dem raum überhaupt nichts zu tun die hatte
tp kaut sind durchnummeriert nach typ 400er sind permanente fehler 500er sind temporäre
fehler 300 ist glaube ich redirektion 200 ist ok 100 habe ich keine ahnung wenn ich
ehrlich bin gibt es 100 htp kauts ne das glaube ich nicht dass es auf wikipedia drauf steht
auf wikipedia steht bestimmt dass das eine legende ist die nicht stimmt ok 100 achso irgendwie
so websocket upgrade gedöns ok htp kats ok was ist das ich für die nächste
naja also so wirklich hat es jetzt damit ja nicht nicht wirklich was zu tun oder
also ich verstehe den sinn der seite wobei man sagen muss dass es zum größten teil nicht
so wirklich passt ok das ist gut hey das sieht fast aus wie chico das ey das ist organ das
sieht original aus wie chico von der farbe her vom schwanz her es können meine seine
mein teppich skin naja wie viele seitenaufrufe macht der preisschamp so ich habe jetzt schon
paar hundert tausend ich glaube das letzte war ich glaube 350.000 oder so hatte der jetzt
ungefähr schon und nix monetarisiert ich bezahle sogar noch drauf ja du hast den preisschamp
im in home assist eingebunden excellent ja ich muss euch aber mal jetzt ehrlich sagen
ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher wie lange ich den preisschamp noch betreibe weil also ich
schalte jetzt nicht instant ab oder so weil das problem ist dass ich das zu pflegen als
doch etwas mehr arbeit rausgestellt hat als ich gedacht habe der crawler also die die
typen die den den den das das repo vom das guitar projekt von dem crawler betreiben
die sind nicht so schnell was deutsche shops update angeht also das heißt eigentlich müsste
ich das selbst machen und ich habe das ja mit der switch mit der switch habe ich ja
schon selbst gemacht die switch habe ich selbst schon eingefügt das das hat ja funktioniert
aber ich habe keinen bock den graben selbst zu pflegen ich habe auch alternator mein factory
total viel selbst geupdatet und ich müsste eigentlich permanent den graben street merchant
ist das auf github was dahinter crawlt ne amazon ist mit affiliate links der rest nicht
ne so dynamisch sind die seiten gar nicht die shop urls zu den produkten sind immer
die gleichen aber die produkte wechseln halt öfters mal guck die shop links sind immer
die gleichen siehst hier unten wenn da draufklickst kommst du bei mein factory raus immer bei
dieser seite aber die produkte wechseln halt öfters mal und deswegen also der pflegeaufwand
ist relativ hoch ich weiß nicht ob ich das lange also ich werde es wahrscheinlich laufen
lassen bis das zeug wieder halbwegs verfügbar ist und dann ja
das ist ja schon recht großes open source die aber in leber beim street merchant direkt
mit als bei mir und die sind halt nicht so hinterher
im anbetracht der tatsache dass mich der kram ja auch 35 bis 40 euro im monat kostet ich
meine das sind es sind drei crawler server ein frontend server und einen analytics server
aber der kostet nur 250
ich wurde behaise erwähnt ne oder wer hat mich denn behaise erwähnt bestimmt irgendwo
im forum oder so
jetzt war es wirklich einer behaise was ins forum geschrieben
das sind keine affiliate links ne ne nur amazon ist ein affiliate link wenn das alles also
hätte ich überhaupt einen affiliate also die meisten shops haben teilweise gar also
außer alternate mindfactory glaube ich haben die meisten shops gar keine affiliate programme
und für alternate und mindfactory will ich mich da nicht extra anmelden jetzt ganz ehrlich
ich glaube nicht dass ich das großartig lohnt da müsste ich das wirklich für alles machen
nein das track ich nicht ich tracke gar nichts ich tracke gar nichts das einzige was mein
analytics macht ist seitenaufrufe zählen komplett ohne irgendwie user bezogene dinger
aber die preise sind schon echt heftig oder guckt euch das mal an 2000 leute es ist billiger
geworden kommt mal sieben tage billiger geworden von 3000 3200 verkauft dem doch wer soll das
dann kaufen von 3200 rüber aber hier da ist es da war es mal 2002 also die preise aber
für die preisentwicklung ist der preis chat tatsächlich ganz cool also den graf finde
ich zum beispiel viele aussagen kräftiger als jetzt haben wir mal mein ver er bei bei
geiz halt oder so pc king kann ich doch pc king ist drin
die case king case case king geht nicht ab pc king ist drin allerdings wahrscheinlich
nicht die richtigen urls zur grafikkarte doppelklick auf den keks öffnet save png was doppelklick
auf den keks ist zum den chat plin zu machen flash bang hardware radne die verkaufen ja
auch keine einzelnen sachen ich habe die extra gefragt ob er will das lohnt sich nicht verkaufen
quasi nix einzeln weiß jam punkt ok machen wir mal google suche ob mich jemand erwähnt
hat die letzte letzte woche ne nur reddit reddit hat mich erwähnt reddit
ah ne hier golem golem ne ne sind keine 8 surfer 3 crawler also 3 triple core crawler
ein dual core web frontend und den single core analytik ist der preis champ kostet aber
halt trotzdem 40 euro im monat exquisite hacker mans also letzten monat hatte ich 99 euro
klatt 99 euro serverkosten bei hetzner aber das waren auch die ganzen versuche mit dabei
mit den 16 core kisten und so so jetzt gucke ich auch mal questions rein der traffic kostet
mal nix ab 20 terabyte kostet das was allerdings bezieht sich das auf über 20 terabyte ich
glaube ausgehend wahrscheinlich wollen die nicht dass man von dort irgendwelche komischen
dinger macht ich glaube inborn traffic oder umgedreht war immer umsonst also im prinzip
im prinzip ist der traffic nahezu unlimited macht er macht er derauer der power nicht
werbung für hetzner doch doch contabo ist auch nicht günstiger als hetzner kostet sogar
noch wahrscheinlich ein bisschen mehr und die machen riesenakt mit mit personal ausweis
oder identität bestätigen personalausweis geduld hetzner ist da total unkompliziert
das hetzner rz virtuell betreten geht das mal hetzner rz haben die so einen rundgang
hast mal ein link das gucken wir uns jetzt an 360 tour hier das hetzner rz sieht aus
wie eine tankstelle von außen oder
auf dem field to home automation zu hausen also wenn du es auf dem raspberry pi haustest
dann nur mit ssd sonst ist so lahm ich habe es auf einer low power quad core intel kiste
wo auch mal ganzes andere zeug läuft ok wir machen das rundgang bei hetzner aber man kann
nicht mal mit ssd laufen und wenn es gibt nur vier bilder ist es ernsthaft nur vier
ist das alles ok wo gehts da rein hier lang alles klar ok ok wo gehts rein ich will ins
rz hier hetzner die bedienung davon ist aber ziemlich sackig und die hätten das mal unbedingt
einem schönen tag aufnehmen sollen so rein marketing technisch jetzt erst mal erst mal
kurz nur mal schön vom chef angucken ich bin schon jetzt gelandet hier kommt man wieder
raus ich will nicht bei hetzner rein ich will dahin ah geht nicht jetzt gehen wir bei hetzner
im hintereingang rein hier geht nicht weiter ok ok was war denn das hetzner online we love
bits do you ah da kann man sich da kann man sich als professioneller display lecker bewerben
ok jetzt gehen wir da rein hier gehts nicht gehts nicht weiter ich hab so den tick auch
paar games ich lauf immer dahin wo das spiel nicht will dass ich hinlauf so da gehts rein
eine runde hetzner werbevideo exzellent einladendste warte ecke aller zeiten da würde ich ja gerne
warten sacker in der ecke die empfang äußerst einladende warte ecke stell dir mal vor so
irgendwie du gehst da rein so hast du dich da beworben ja nehmen sie hier mal kurz platz
und machen sie sich bequem zum glück haben sie die tür aufgemalt dass du nicht die tür
gegen den kopf gehauen kriegst du kannst die tür nicht in den kopf ins gesicht bekommen
es sei denn einer dem macht die seite auf ok wo gehts weiter da kann man rein da kann
man rein wir gehen zum notausgang ach da kommen wir her jetzt haben die aber cool gemacht
hier darf man nicht hier darf man auch nicht weiter ok ach yes rechenzentrum exzellent
exzellent guck mal sogar sogar zweistöckiges etzhet wisst ihr wie das aussieht wie das
sieht aus wie die fabrikhalle aus warzone oder alternativ wie die fabrikhalle auf battlefield
3 auf auf auf dieser einen dlc map diese diese herbst dlc map ich habe vergessen wie
sie heißt sieht genauso aus die hätten aber die steuerung unbedingt mit tastatur machen
müssen ach man kann hier nicht weiter aber guck mal hier ganz viele exquisite netzwerkabel
so gucken wir uns das etzhet mal weiter an zack daneben dürfen wir nicht lang äh wo
gehts runter ok etzhet hier dürfen wir nicht durch dürfen nur dahin ok ich sehe viele
netzteile gut das ist irgendwas von hinten dürfen wir so ein würfel reingucken klimaanlage
arme dürfen sogar reingucken ja gut sieht halt ok was zum was ist das was was bin ich
sehend ein desktop mainboard mit vga ja ich würde sagen desktop und desktop mainboard
mit vga und dvi die verwenden keine rek hardware ja das habe ich auch schon gelesen und ich
finde die idee gar nicht so doof ich finde die idee gar nicht so doof weil du kannst
die desktop hardware easy tauschen wenn die wenn da mal einer ausfällt ist nicht so wild
und es ist wahrscheinlich einfach viel viel billiger ich würde es auch ehrlich ohne scheiß
ich würde es auch so machen hast du das etzhet nicht deutlich erst begutachten also wenn
ich sowas anbieten würde oder wenn ich mir irgendwas das würde ich auch so machen ja
das ist das etzhet von von hetzner ich dachte man kann ein bisschen anderweitig durchlaufen
und ich muss hier aus sonst verliert die orientierung da kommen wir her aha netz teil action huge
netz teil ach hier geht es dann gar nicht mehr weiter das sehe ich das richtig gibt
nur den anfang vom etzhet mehr gibt es nicht hier waren wir ja schon drin hier waren wir
schon ja ich bin so sehr in der cloud dass ich gerade sogar durch cloud rechenzentrum
laufen kann man muss sich ja man muss sich hier merken wo man wo man lang geht ok das
ist verwirrend so da war man jetzt schon drin da war man ist da eingang und irgendwo konnte
man jetzt noch rein das ist jetzt ein anderes das ist das hetzner rechenzentrum cooling
keck-keck-wait ah nee nee nee wait a minute also hier geht es hier geht es wieder
warum hat er die bodenplatte draußen da wo er steht
warum genau ist da die bodenplatte draußen
das ist klasse echt warum das ist kein klasse hier siehst du doch neben direkt das auflage
ding stimmt die deckenlampe spiegelt sich ich habe jetzt gedacht die spiegelt sich
da unten spiegelt sich tatsächlich hier oben hier ging es raus oder ja ok hier geht es
weiter gut jetzt doch halt aus dürfen wir hier auch weiter ach hier war ok wir haben
danach haben wir alles gesehen darf ich den rack aufmachen please da reingucken das sind
jetzt ok das sind jetzt 19 zoll dinger da für den schrank ich will den schrank aufmachen
das hätte das wäre noch cool immer noch ein schrank aufmachen können fühle ich mich
fast fühle ich mich fast wie beim rechten rechenzentrums rundgang ok mehr geht nicht
ab wo ist da noch raised floors da doppelt das aber so diese zwischenböden sind ja das
ist ja normal das hat eigentlich fast jedes a das ist allerwichtigste gut zu wissen dass
das hier ist ähnlich die runde kacken bei hetzner wollte ich schon immer mal falls ich
jemals da bin das wichtigste ist schon mal geregelt ah hier ok das sieht tatsächlich
jetzt ein bisschen einladender aus die warte ecke im oldschool telephone ein bisschen bunker
mäßig sieht es ja aus aber immerhin hier hängt so moderne kunst an der wand das lockert
die atmosphäre auf man darf nicht fotografieren ok login login ist raus leute ob die qr code
fehlerkorrektur so gut ist dass man das scannen kann also qr code fehlerkorrektur ist echt
poggers aber ne da erkennt er selbst nix drauf ne da erkennt er nix drauf nope keine
chance ich probiere es gerade mit meinem handy klappt nicht nee das wäre cool aber qr code
also qr code fehlerkorrektur ist echt hart also klaut man manchmal gar nicht wie gut
ich das erkennen so eine runde kaffeestellz kann man um die eck kann man um die eck gucken
was ist hier ach komm mal es kommt mir bekannt vor fast aus wie bei mir das ist aber die
einsamste techniker ecke des ganzen ladens hier oder was macht man für was genau ist
diese ecke da also was ist die was ist der sinn davon aufnahmeprüfung meint ihr da
einfach einen rollwagen zieht den kram raus der kaputt ist und repariert das dann hier
um die ecke ich mein wäre ganz sinnvoll bevor man da irgendwie sonst wohin fährt aber das
sieht so das sieht so weiß ich so so kark irgendwie und ja keine ahnung hier wir haben
das hetsen der rechenzentrum gesehen mehr gibt es nicht oh nee wir haben manche wege
leute haben die wege nicht gefunden hier ist das loading dock data center colocation da
waren wir drin kaffeteria oh quake wie sind die da jetzt hingekommen moment wie welche
tür ging hier aha da muss man von der anderen seite rein ok die bedienung verwirrt mich
übelst da kommt man auf die rampe ok rampen stellts die treppe da hoch da gehts in die
kaffeteria hoch ja gut kein wunder dass wir das nicht gefunden haben da kam ja aus dem
set aus nicht hin bisschen wenig leute hier überall ich hab nicht ich hab nicht eine
person gesehen bisher na gut klar die sind aus dem bild gegangen aber trotzdem der obligatorische
tisch kicker den wahrscheinlich keiner verwendet der muss aber einfach da sein weil irgendwie
viele so it unternehmen der meinungen sind tisch kicker alle wollen sie tisch kickern
und im endeffekt tisch kickern dann auch keiner so ah yes huge raucherecke da steht der bus
mit china touristen davor ok na so siehts bei hetzer also aus jetzt wissen wir bescheid
iso 27.001 zertifiziert na dann mustangfahrer stufe 1 sangst du für den sub massive sub
chat iq increase was stand da knabenchor wirklich da der papst freut sich
so erstmal alles zumachen lup erst mal alles schließen alles schließen zack zack zack
und ganz wichtig vm vm löschen ja also die zfs geschichte jetzt noch mal zusammenzufassen
finde ich echt nice wie sie es mittlerweile gemacht haben ist relativ easy aber den install
aber der install vorgang nervt mich immer noch das heißt ich würde ich nicht benutzen
also nicht mit dem installer und nicht standardmäßig so auf meiner kiste hier aber an sich haben
sie schon cool gemacht oh mist ich wollte muss die fragen ja noch schnell durchgehen
schnell wieder anschalten lul ja jetzt jetzt kostet viel wir bezahlen für unser backup
rechnzentrum auf der arbeit 30.000 euro stromkosten im monat habe ich letztens irgendwo gehört
kannst du das ganze nicht über ansible machen boah das was ich heute gemacht habe über
ansible scripten stelle ich mir ein bisschen schwierig vor das komplette debian setup und
die mit den reboots und alles ne cloud hq in offenbach kenne ich nicht aber schadet
auf jeden fall nix mehr alternativen ist immer nicht verkehrt es gab ja mal das gerücht
dass in hannau amazon rechnzentrum aufmacht so ein gewerbegebiet komplett kauft und da
was aufmacht habe ich schon überlegt bewerbung bei amazon ist raus aber das wäre wahrscheinlich
nur in den cloud standort geworden und da hab ich keinen bock drauf weil amazon techniker
will ich nicht sein also amazon sackhachenfahrer mehr hätte es an der stelle nicht gegeben
da haben wir doch mal ein video geguckt von irgendeinem kerl der glaubt das war host unlimited
auf youtube nein habe ich nicht gespielt ich habe es vor aber erst wenn ich mir 3d brillen
mal irgendwann kaufen sollte naja gut was soll großartig passieren du musst ja da immer
noch reinkommen und wenn hast du trotzdem keine ahnung wo was drauf ist also nicht dass
das so wild ist und die haben sicherlich noch ein paar räume die sie nicht gezeigt haben
wo die stonks sachen sind das ist mancharo mit e3wm das kannst du gar nicht runterladen
du musst mancharo installieren und dann den e3wm einrichten ich glaube es gibt sogar ein
offizielles e3 mancharo flavor mittlerweile aber das hat mir nicht gefallen ja deswegen
hat die blitzkorn auch gesagt e3 mega s hatte ich
home assistant habe ich wie gesagt in einer vm auf einer low power quadcore intel kiste
ich glaube das zieht sich alles auf die deluxe installation alles bin ich durch easy easy
as fuck chat ich geh ins bett wir sehen uns bis zum nächsten mal ich hoffe es hat euch
gefallen war eine recht spontane geschichte
wir sehen uns bis dann